thank you very much the event at the
white house was to talk prescription
prices
but donald trump couldn't help talking
about the election claiming
pharmaceutical companies delayed news of
a covered vaccine to hurt him
politically
big farmer ran millions of dollars of
negative advertisements against me
during the
campaign which i won by the way but you
know we'll find that out
uh almost 74 million votes
we had big pharma against us we had the
media against
us we had big tech against us
we had a lot of dishonesty against us
while joe biden spent his birthday
meeting with democratic congressional
leaders to talk
post-election plans donald trump was
meeting republicans from michigan
the white house denying reports the
president wants them to stop the state
certifying biden's win there he
routinely meets with lawmakers from all
across the country
but one democrat from michigan says this
is anything but a routine meeting joe
biden won the state of michigan
by a margin 14 times greater
than donald trump won our state four
years ago
the president is trying to i don't know
what word to call it
is it cheat his way to victory by
pressuring local
officials after the meeting the two
republicans said they'd heard no new
information to change joe biden's
victory in the state
adding the results certification process
should be free
from threats and intimidation and joe
biden's legal team
called it an abuse of course it's an
abuse of office
it's an open attempt to intimidate
election officials
georgia is the latest state to certify a
joe biden victory
after a manual recount of 5 million
votes he becomes the first democrat to
win the presidential race in the state
since 1992. there are two recounts
underway in counties in wisconsin but
it's unlikely they'll change the result
there
president-elect joe biden now stands on
306 electoral college votes
exactly the same number donald trump
achieved four years ago
when he claimed a landslide victory alan
fisher al-jazeera
at the white house